58 59 60 60 secondi minuto in questo
minuto appena trascorso ben cinque
bambini sono morti di fame è un dato il
logico prima che ingiusto cosa si può
fare per evitarlo bisogna produrre forse
più cibo no i dati ci dicono ben altro
ci dicono ad esempio che siamo circa 6
miliardi di persone a questo mondo ma si
produce cibo per ben 12 miliardi di
persone
questo è il paradosso si produce cibo
per tutti ma non tutti ne hanno
abbastanza da mangiare
questo è il paradosso della fame e
dell'abbondanza e il dato appena
menzionato è un dato a cui se ne
aggiungono altri un alimento su tre
viene perso in un anno lungo tutta la
catena alimentare un miliardo e tre di
tonnellate viene sprecato sarebbe
alimentazione sufficiente per sanare
quattro volte tanto
tutti gli affamati di questa terra e in
più questo spreco e un danno anche per
il nostro ambiente 24,5 milioni di
tonnellate di co2 sono il risultato di
tutto il cibo prodotto e non utilizzato
qual è allora il rimedio
bisogna forse trovare l'algoritmo che
consenta di distribuire gli avanzi di
cibo a quelli che sono gli avanzi del
mondo no perché
amati non sono avanzi dell'umanità sono
persone sono persone che hanno
esattamente i diritti che hanno che
abbiamo tutti noi
e qui entriamo nel secondo paradosso
il paradosso della doppia malnutrizione
perché lo ms ricorda che la
malnutrizione non è solo quella per
difetto ma anche quella per eccesso e di
obesità si muore così come si muore di
fame
vedete quindi che 672 milioni di persone
obese di fronte a 821 milioni di
affamati è un dato che non ha alcun
senso è un dato di fronte al quale
bisogna reagire perché è un dato che ci
dimostra che il diritto al cibo è
violato e proprio quando un diritto è
violato è proprio lì che occorre
garantirlo e tutelarlo per dare a
ciascuno a ciascun malnutrito sia esso
affamato si è speso dignità ed ecco
quindi quello che ho imparato nella nei
tre anni in cui ho elaborato la mia tesi
sul diritto al cibo adeguato ovvero che
non basta mettere in sicurezza gli
alimenti occorre mettere in sicurezza
innanzitutto i diritti il diritto al
cibo adeguato e la via
ma cos'è il diritto al cibo non è food
security non è soltanto cioè accesso a
quantità e qualità sufficienti di cibo e
non è neanche solo food safety ovvero
accesso al cibo che sia sano dal punto
di vista igienico sanitario e non è
nemmeno food law ossia il diritto che
descrive come i cibi devono essere
prodotti trasformati e distribuiti è
qualcosa di più è un accesso regolare
permanente libero in quantità e qualità
adeguate e sufficienti culturalmente
accettabili per una vita
di chicca e fisica individuale e
collettiva che sia priva di paure e
degna la chiave di lettura è tutta in
quella parola dignità
il diritto al cibo non è un nuovo
diritto è un diritto antico riconosciuto
dalla dichiarazione universale dei
diritti dell'uomo del 48 e poi
riconosciuto ancora in numerose
convenzioni internazionali che ne
attuano diverse dimensioni soprattutto
nei confronti delle persone più
vulnerabili ma il rai time il tempo
opportuno il carroccio del diritto al
cibo e recente degli anni 90 è seguito
un dibattito ampio portato avanti da
nobel amartya sen
o da attivisti come la via campesina che
ancora lottano per la sovranità
alimentare e ora è un diritto monitorato
da alcune importanti agenzie delle
nazioni unite come la fao food programme
e lo speciale relatore sul diritto al
cibo ma se gli affamati e anche gli
obesi hanno un diritto al cibo adeguato
chi ha il dovere di garantire questo
diritto noi tutti attori privati e
soggetti pubblici i primi depositari di
questo dovere sono tuttavia i soggetti
pubblici che hanno il dovere di
rispettare proteggere e rendere
effettivo il diritto al cibo come
attraverso gli strumenti ordinariamente
a disposizione degli stati e delle loro
articolazioni come le autorità locali
ovvero produrre norme coerenti produrre
politiche efficaci e correlati servizi
pubblici e
garantire un adeguato sistema
giudiziario che consenta a tutti di
tutelare il diritto nei diversi casi
concreti
se guardiamo la mappa della fame il
colore celeste ci mostra che la fame è
meno forte e meno sentita nei paesi del
nord del mondo ma segue abbiamo la mappa
del diritto al cibo
questa ci dice che il diritto al cibo è
più garantito nei cosiddetti paesi del
sud del mondo e il viola e l'azzurro
sono i paesi in cui il diritto al cibo e
contenuto è garantito attraverso una
legge una norma costituzionale
avreste mai immaginato voi che il
diritto al cibo è meglio garantito nella
costituzione sudafricana in quella
italiana o in quella brasiliana emiliana
che in una qualunque delle costituzioni
europee
eppure così ma vi illustro un paio di
casi giurisprudenziali sono solo casi
per dimostrarvi come questo diritto può
essere tutelato in sudafrica è famoso il
caso dei pescatori che erano stati
espropriati del diritto di accedere
liberamente alla pesca a causa di una
legge che rendeva commercializzabile i
diritti di pesca
grazie a una procedura giudiziaria sono
riusciti ad accedere non solo al diritto
al cibo e al pescato in quanto derrata
alimentare ma anche il diritto di fare
di quella un'attività economica perché
dignità significa accedere al cibo nel
modo più dignitoso possibile e
normalmente il lavoro per procurarsi il
cibo è ciò che rende degna una persona
in europa dove il diritto al cibo non è
riconosciuto in nessuna costituzione
tuttavia altre norme europee hanno
garantito alcune dimensioni del diritto
al cibo e vanno tutelato soprattutto nei
confronti delle persone più vulnerabili
in particolare coloro privati della
libertà personale come i detenuti ad
esempio l'alimentazione forzata è stata
denunciata come addirittura tortura ma
l'alimentazione forzata praticata in
modo violento e volutamente doloroso e
non finalizzato a nutrimento della
persona
come pure la privazione prolungata di
cibo è stata qualificata come un
trattamento inumano e degradante e in
italia
in italia non esiste una norma
costituzionale che garantisce il diritto
al cibo ma ci sono numerose disposizioni
della costituzione che ne garantiscono
le sue diverse dimensioni
la dimensione sanitaria la dimensione
educativa quella laburisti ca quella
economica
quindi abbiamo un buon pacchetto di
diritti che posso su cui poterci passare
e anche molte politiche pubbliche sono
abbastanza efficienti da garantirne
l'attuazione
lo sai che manca quello che manca è un
trait union se il sistema di protezione
del diritto al cibo italiano potesse
essere paragonato a un albero
quello che manca il tronco che possa
collegare bene le radici dei diritti
fondamentali con le ramificazioni delle
politiche pubbliche
diversamente si producono altri
paradossi un esempio in italia il
diritto di essere curati per patologie
alimentari e garantito attraverso un
buon servizio sanitario nazionale
ma il diritto di mangiare un pasto
quotidianamente lo sharp per esempio non
è garantito allo stesso modo e con la
stessa forza per cui si arriva
all'assurdo che è garantito il diritto
gran salute alimentare ma non la sua pre
condizione ovvero il diritto di essere
nutriti altro esempio l'acqua
l'acqua anche grazie al recente
referendum è un bene comune e l'accesso
pubblico all'acqua è garantito da un
servizio pubblico locale
ma il cibo il cibo è una merce e la sua
distribuzione è rimessa al mercato tutto
questo ha un senso le politiche locali i
servizi pubblici essenziali che
garantiscono l'accesso al cibo si fanno
soprattutto a livello locale quindi è
molto importante che la normativa che lo
garantisca sia anche di livello locale e
quello che ha fatto la città di torino
che 23 anni fa ha introdotto nel suo
statuto che la carta fondamentale il
riconoscimento del diritto al cibo
adeguato
torino è la prima città italiana che ha
operato
questo riconoscimento e qui chiudo con
una nota personale perché per me è stato
molto importante rientrando presso
l'ufficio cooperazione internazionale
pace dove lavoro al termine del mio
dottorato avere avuto la possibilità da
parte dei miei amministratori di poter
istruire il procedimento che ha portato
a deliberare l'introduzione del diritto
al cibo nello statuto della città e
questo mi ha consentito di dare un esito
a quelli che erano stati i miei studi e
di vedere la teoria diventare prassi la
ricerca diventare pratica amministrativa
la teoria di diventare azione e questo
oggi è l'augurio mio che faccio anche a
tutti voi
l'augurio che possiate sviluppare entro
queste mura o le mura dei vostri atenei
le vostre idee le vostre idee belle e
che queste possano diventare progetto
progetto che abbia un impatto sociale
forse piccolo ma significativo una
goccia che insieme a tante altre
contribuisce a riempire il mare del
cambiamento
e a questo punto la sfida vi sfido a
venire qua troviamoci qua tra cinque o
dieci anni
vediamo però io al vostro posto e voi al
mio a raccontarmi in che modo le vostre
idee sono diventate progetto sono
diventate prassi voi ci sarete io vi
aspetto
grazie